in 2020 one story has consumed
everything but in 2021
the world will start looking to life
beyond the pandemic
[Music]
so behind the headlines what are the
other moments you should be watching out
for
in the year ahead
[Music]
from the launch of an asteroid smashing
spaceship
to the event that could help the world
turn a corner on climate change
here are five stories set to shape the
post-covered world
in 2021 democracy will be especially
tested
there will be an abundance of elections
many postponed from 2020 by the pandemic
and in fragile democracies autocratic
leaders will use the excuse of covert 19
to crack down on opposition
such as in uganda which is due to hold
its presidential election
in january maria is a 25 year old
activist
who is campaigning for the opposition
candidate bobby wine
but ugandan authorities have banned
rallies because of covert 19.
they're not implementing covet
guidelines
with people that who live day-to-day
lives
they're only implementing these
guidelines with opposition politicians
that is all so
it is just an excuse
at a recent rally police arrested bobby
wine
accusing him of flouting covert 19
restrictions
when they were arresting bobby wine what
they did was to first
block all the vehicles that were around
and only his vehicle was allowed to go
in front
what are they doing now they paper
sprayed all his
bodyguards those the personal bodyguards
not the ones the electoral commission
gave
gave to us they paper sprayed them and
they were beaten
protests broke out almost a thousand
people were arrested
and 45 were killed crackdowns
on opposition politicians are not just
happening
in uganda
since the pandemic started democracy and
human rights have deteriorated in 80
countries
according to freedom house a think tank
the largest number
are in africa this is certainly a
problem in in africa because there are
many countries there that have
made a partial transition towards
democracy and respect for human rights
but because it's fairly recent
and the institutions that protect it are
are not particularly strong there's
always the danger of backsliding
uganda's president yawari masevani has
been in power for almost 35
years in 2017 he changed the country's
constitution
to allow him to serve a sixth term
the pandemic has made it easier to block
opposition and dissent
all we want is our freedom back all we
want is to change
power and so that power comes back to
the people and the institutions that
must protect the people
that is all we want maria can't even
campaign on social media
government rules brought in in 2020
require many internet users to register
with a regulator
before they can publish anything online
across the world
91 countries have experienced new or
increased restrictions
on the news media as a result of the
pandemic
i think there's a real danger that
democracy will continue to retreat
in 2021 i'm hoping that eventually
we'll be able to get widespread vaccines
out there and that will make it easier
for people to to gather together and to
organize which is what you need to be
able to do if you're going to resist
tyranny
we must campaign so that we win this
election we
are ready to fight for our victory it is
either bullet
or a ballot
[Music]
2021 will be a tipping point for
electric cars
as more manufacturers roll out their
electric range
suddenly there's going to be a huge
array of electric vehicles for people to
choose from
in the autumn the gas guzzling suv brand
of general motors hummer
will start production on all electric
cars
and at the end of the year elon musk's
tesla
will launch its futuristic looking cyber
truck
so i present you the cyber truck the
cyber truck may not be to everyone's
taste
i think that's significant because the
american market
the real profits there are to be made on
pickups
um so tesla have come out with their own
version of the pickup the cyber truck
the electric hummer is trying to tap
into that market it's that america's
biggest and most profitable market
investment in the electric revolution
has surged over 250 firms
are currently manufacturing electric
vehicles and 47 battery factories
are under construction tesla
the market leader has seen its share
price surge
it's now so valuable it's been added to
the s p 500
america's main stock market index
putting it in the same brackets as
companies
like apple and microsoft tesla is a
remarkable
story no car company has gone from
nothing to where tesla is
in such a a rapid period of time
so you have to take your hat off to elon
musk
for doing that
tesla's success convinced established
car makers
that there was a market for electric
cars the car companies made the biggest
bet
on the future is volkswagen
which has invested huge sums
but all car companies are introducing
electric models every week you hear
about
a new plan to electrify an old model
or bring out a new model from various
car
companies so it really is picking up the
pace
although all car sales dropped in 2020
in 2021 they are expected to pick up
again and sales of battery-powered
vehicles
are projected to grow rapidly over the
next decade
2021 is just the start if more
governments commit
to future bans on the sale of petrol and
diesel cars the growth in the electric
vehicle sector could accelerate
even more
in november all eyes will be on glasgow
scotland
as world leaders meet for the un's
climate change summit
known as cop 26 it was originally
scheduled for 2020
but postponed due to the pandemic if it
had gone ahead as planned
cop 26 would have marked five years
since the paris agreement
built into the paris agreement was this
ratchet
mechanism that basically said
governments
need to every five years increase the
promises to cut emissions
the paris agreement set a target of
limiting global warming
to between 1.5 and 2 degrees celsius
above pre-industrial temperatures but
experts predict that the pledges
governments made in 2015
would not be enough to achieve this
target
so this ratchet mechanism the purpose of
cop26
is really to get closer to this target
of 1.5 to 2 degrees celsius and what's
needed for that
are bigger better promises to cut
national emissions
it looks likely that 2021 will be the
boldest year ever for tackling climate
change
so the eu has said that it will reach
net zero emissions by 2050.
climate change is caused by us so in
other words
it's up to us to make a turnaround they
have
an expansive package of policies that
they will be
expanding on and agreeing on in 2021 for
how they
head towards that goal the surprise
announcement really
of this year came in september when xi
jinping
announced that china would be heading
towards
carbon neutrality by 2060. the details
of how china does this are still unclear
and are anticipated at some point in
2021
in america donald trump has undermined
global efforts to tackle global warming
we are going to put our coal miners
back to work in 2021
this could all change what is our
mandate
i believe it's this and the battle
to save our planet by getting climate
under control
[Music]
joe biden is going to mark a real u-turn
in particular american foreign climate
policy biden has promised to
put america back into the paris
agreement pretty much as soon as he
enters
the oval office and as such america will
once again
be influencing global climate politics
america is the world's second biggest
emitter joe biden has promised to make
the country carbon neutral by 2050
his greatest challenge however is
getting these ambitious pledges through
congress
there is a lot of ease in making these
long-term promises
it's a lot harder to back those up with
the real
policies at home that are going to
achieve them but having the european
union the united states
china all headed towards some kind of
mid-century target 2050 2060 eliminating
their missions
should give confidence to the rest of
the countries that they can
also amp up their target so all of that
put together
means that 2021 could really mark a
turning point in international climate
negotiations
[Music]
in 2021 the eagerly awaited next
installment
in the james bond franchise will be
released
as shown in this slick trailer
why would i betray you we all have our
secrets
but its release could be eclipsed at the
box office by a movie most people in the
west
may never even have heard
[Music]
the slapstick comedy detective chinatown
3
will help china's box office to take
more money than america's
to become the biggest in the world
for a century hollywood has ruled the
movie world
now it's china's turn
[Music]
hollywood was the first kind of global
truly global film industry which
exported
worldwide and it has held that dominance
for a long time
now with um china becoming the biggest
box office
and it feels like a milestone simply
because it sort of
shakes that hollywood dominance of them
china's cinema industry has been growing
for a number of years
but in 2021 projections show america's
box office revenues stagnating
as china's continued to rise china's
building
more screens particularly in third tier
and fourth tier cities
so it was something that was going to
happen it was just a question what year
was going to happen
the trend is there in america film fans
are shunning the cinema
in favor of video on demand but in china
both online streaming and cinema
attendance are on the rise
the key element of it is the is the
young audience
um who go to the cinema regularly um you
know going out with friends to go to the
cinema
still something of an event an
experience china's rise to the top of
the box office
has been helped by the pandemic
hollywood delayed productions
and movie theaters have been closed yet
in china
cinemas are now back up to almost 75
capacity
and production of new films is steaming
ahead
they are not too reliant on foreign
productions
in a way that they were perhaps
previously um nowadays something like 65
to 75
of the cinema slate in china is actually
uh local content and the budgets of
those films that have
risen quite a lot in recent years
despite this big american films still do
very well in china the eighth
installment of the fast and furious
series
took nearly twice as much in china as it
did in north america
but hollywood's reliance on chinese
ticket sales has started a worrying
trend
[Music]
well there's a lot of self-censorship no
question
china will not always tell you and
normally will not tell you what you have
to do to get the film into the china
market
they will let you decide and you end up
self-censoring more than china might
censor you
so that that can be a problem tilda
swinton's marvel character in doctor
strange
the ancient one possibility was changed
from a tibetan to a celt
in part it was thought to placate china
but despite the soft power china may
wield on hollywood films
it's unlikely it'll succeed in exporting
its own blockbusters
anytime soon it's very hard for china
given the stories they tell
given their emphasis on the domestic
market
given the issue of dubbing and
subtitling
for them to do very well overseas
while a lot of those um local films
from the chinese industry are very
culturally specific
i think we might well see western
studios
taking on titles that performed well in
china and remaking them
for a u.s or a western audience
while much of next year will be focused
on protecting the world from dangers on
earth
some scientists will be focusing on how
to defend the planet
from threats in outer space in july 2021
nasa will launch the world's first trial
in planetary defense
basically we're purposely slamming a
spacecraft into an asteroid
to move it a little bit and this is the
sort of thing that you might want to do
if an asteroid was
on a course to hit the earth this might
sound like the plot of a hollywood
blockbuster
but the threat of an asteroid hitting
earth is real
a tiny asteroid streaking across
southern russia
just seven years ago an undetected
meteor exploded over the russian city of
chelyabinsk
injuring at least 1 200 people
i think the chelyabinsk impact really
brought a lot of visibility to the fact
that
this is something that happens to the
earth all of the time
if something like that happens over a
large city you can get this sort of
unfortunate devastation
something that's tell your bank's size
happens every few decades to maybe
100 years or so as you go up to
something that's
a bit bigger sort of 160 meters
that's more rare but the amount of
damage that it would cost could
potentially
wipe out a large region perhaps a small
country
if it was over one of those this is a
rare event
but the consequences are so big and
devastating
that it really makes sense to take a
step to do something about it
nasa's double asteroid redirection test
or dart
will practice defending earth by
altering the course of an asteroid
using what's known as kinetic impactor
technology
this asteroid is not a threat to the
earth it's not going to hit the earth in
the foreseeable future
but we do know that earth is hit by
asteroids all the time
and so we really want to take this first
step to develop the technology to do
something about that
if we needed to in the future
the target is the asteroid didimas which
is orbited by a smaller asteroid
demorphis the dart spacecraft
will hit the moonlet adjusting its path
and shortening its orbit by several
minutes
the impact will happen in 2022 when the
asteroid is close enough to earth
for scientists to be able to study the
change in momentum
using powerful telescopes the dart
mission
is just one part of a wider worldwide
effort
in planetary defense knowing where
everything is
is really a crucial foundation for
planetary defenses
finding all the asteroids tracking them
and then being ready to do something
about them
in order to take that next step and turn
what was science fiction into a reality
of being able to do something about
asteroids
the probability of a giant asteroid
hitting earth
is extremely small but if 2020 has shown
anything
it's that it pays to be prepared for the
unexpected
i'm tom standage editor of the economist
annual the world in 2021
click on the link opposite for more
analysis of the year ahead
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel
you